let's give this a shot okay i gotta piss
and [ __ ] dude
hey can i just ask you why you're riding
their butt like that and speeding man
i'm running his license plate
because everybody else is speeding why
are you speeding i was only going 60.
speed limit's 40. okay we'll buy
all right in favor oh give me the weed
too no i i have a
oh oh yeah i have a medical marijuana
step out i have a car
all right all right stop man dude
this doesn't even feel real like the way
his his head pokes in like a [ __ ]
almond the sun the speed
the speed sunglasses bro and like
when have you ever built for speed dude
when have you ever seen a cop
like yell at you and then tell you to
get lost like that
like that is never happened
yeah you broke the law and you know what
uh i'm just reminding you that you're
[ __ ]
wrong get out of here it's funny they're
both
wrong about the speed limit i was going
60. it's
40. it's actually 50.
it's 40. bro you see how quick he
reaches for his [ __ ] waist
yeah that's that's scary man that's
[ __ ] terrifying right at which this
just escalated
yeah this dude horrifying this went from
he's like give me the you'd see a
register in his eyes he sees the weed
immediately that's that's cause yeah
probable cause
anyway in his eyes ladies
step out i have a car all right all
right stop man
you want to [ __ ] run your mouth no
problem you came the right guy step out
all right all right stop
oh no that's horrifying
that's
where's the horrifying i have it in my
car but i have this car
i have a weed speed apart
we're not just being detained you're not
under arrest
bro 50 seconds 50 seconds
from a [ __ ] from a traffic stop
to your not being arrested you're being
detained
what some dude someone's saying
someone with a gun saying you want to
run your mouth you came to the right guy
oh yeah yeah terrifying bro yeah
what ends up happening um i didn't
finish the whole clip because i kind of
wanted it to keep
i wanted to keep it genuine so i'm
guessing here
i think that he gets away but that
let's see let's just skip ahead is it in
the original dispensary container
and you're [ __ ] how's that sound
oh my god what
bro this is dark what the [ __ ] god
god help you if there's anything illegal
in this car is it in the original
dispensary container
is it in the original dispensary
container
and you're [ __ ] how's that sound
no [ __ ] mind your own [ __ ] business
next time
whoa yeah it's called shut the [ __ ] up
bro this is like a [ __ ] me
dude this guy needs to not have a gun
and he needs to go to therapy
i pray for his wife man if he has one oh
man this is just
it's just classic abusive power right
here
like this guy just was a little bit
offended that someone said he was
riding a guy's tail yeah that's all it
was yeah
any any level-headed person would be
like yeah i mean
sorry yeah maybe i was or i wasn't or
whatever or get mad but i'm not gonna
get mad to the point of abusing this
position i'm in
bro the way he's like he's like he's
like fainting at him
like he's got him in cuffs and he's
going like what [ __ ]
yeah come at me bro i do have to say the
way he says you're [ __ ]
is it's not funny but it's like
it's making me laugh when has a cop ever
done i've never seen a cop do that
i was into the container you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] man why don't you try oh
there's this new strain of wheat it's
called
your [ __ ] business
oh you got a cushion there you better
get smooshed in here [ __ ]
i'm gonna put you in a container
dude just the way his [ __ ] head his
head and this frame
[Laughter]
is just the [ __ ] what's good you got
weed in there it was good
was it what's up dude i know we're
joking about this but this is
seriously horrifying yeah no it's scary
but
just the [ __ ] dude this guy is a
loser
yeah lunatic bro get out of here man
get this guy off the [ __ ] force look
how fast this goes let's just run that
back one more time bro
how do anger issues like that
hey can i just ask you why hey
hey hey hey
you're riding their butt like that and
speeding man i'm running his license
plate
oh i thought it was the cop that said
hey
i thought
hey can i just ask you why you're riding
there oh what is that and speeding man
i'm running his license plate because
everybody else is speeding why are you
speeding i was only going 60.
speed limit's 40. okay well bye
all right in favor oh give me the weed
too no i i have a
oh oh yeah i have a medical marijuana
step out i have a car
all right all right stop
i don't understand what happened in the
beginning of this yeah
he stopped to like talk to the cop and
tell him
i guess
bro what look at this [ __ ] delusional
ass comment
oh my god this cop is hilarious i think
he said what most officers feel like
hahaha kudos to him he deserves a raise
what no he doesn't
i guess your cool youtube video didn't
turn out the way you thought what what's
happening
my hero chooses ass and lets him go
that's how it's done
dude all these people have abusive
parents what the [ __ ]
i support this type of tantrum from a
cop any day
no
what are you joking me
how is everyone just like so casual that
this dude is like on
full tilt over a [ __ ] traffic stop
that's insane
that's like actually insane how how
like i don't know i just feel like it's
not that crazy to
to to to expect cops just to like
even if the even if that guy was in the
wrong and he and he was speeding and he
talked to the
any you know whatever like was getting
the cops attention
accusing the cop for speeding when he
wasn't even if this guy's in the wrong
the cops should be like just chill about
it yeah okay i wasn't i wasn't speeding
i was running that guy's plate
and like if you have do you have a card
for that weed okay you do okay cool
boom yeah right yeah not that i think
there there is
your behavior should be nothing short of
that what the [ __ ]
you don't be [ __ ] taking out your
anger on civilians no one told you to
[ __ ] bet 2 000 on the [ __ ] eagles
you [ __ ]
this guy's from connecticut so whatever
[ __ ] football team is from over there
losing five grand on your college team
and you're taking it out on the dude
with [ __ ] roachweed
who's probably stoned as [ __ ] and he's
just like hey man why are you running
that guy's plate oh what the [ __ ]
whoa it's 40.
[Laughter]
also one of the comments said this guy
must have teenagers dude
don't yell your kids like that yeah i
pray to god he has no [ __ ] kids this
is literally everyone with abusive
parents oh my god he's hilarious
i love this guy please don't hit me as
well
happy 41st birthday dad i'm 40. yeah
okay sorry sorry
is wild man oh my god
[ __ ] get these people [ __ ] leather
flavored popsicles dude holy [ __ ]
deep throating that [ __ ]
anyway
this is [ __ ] insane
you